you remember this can the sweet sauce
the soft noodle this twist childhood but
did you know that Chef Boyardee was an
actual chef he was his name was Hector
and he made a meat and pasta sauce but
it wasn't Hector sauce that made Chef
Boyardee the household name that it is
today you in big the US military for
that in the 1930s
Hector BRD opened up an Italian
restaurant in Ohio and everyone was like
oh my god I love your sauce so he
started selling it and he sold a lot of
it a lot a lot by 1938 he had opened up
his own factory selling his sauce and
pasta can't ask for Chef Boyardee
spaghetti dinner only about 15 cents a
serving then World War two happened and
a phone call was made
the US military called Hector had said
something like help make food for the
troops he already had the cannon
infrastructure so Hector said all right
his company shifted from a civilian
consumer base to a military one Chef
Boyardee became the largest supplier of
rations to US and Allied forces
production was happening 24/7 by the end
of the war the factory was too large and
the military demand no longer existed
Hector didn't know what to do so he sold
it to this large company called American
Home Products who were all like we got
this they quickly rebranded and
distributed the can as easy to make at
home meals and filled supermarket
shelves across the United States so
today when we buy Chef Boyardee we're
actually eating rebranded World War two
field rations yep
you